so good to see you how are you doing
good i'm doing really well what time is
it for you there
let me check it is um 96 pm near 6 p.m
perfect it is so wonderful to see you
congratulations on another incredible
season you are so so good as penelope
what did it mean for you
to be the gossip queen of this show in
this series
i mean it was really exciting in season
one i sort of knew the secret but had to
keep it secret you know i also didn't do
that well instead did did tell people i
was like you know ladies and gents in
his week um
from the world but then it was really
fun in season two knowing that that was
sort of blown wide open and then we got
to explore all those sides to her in the
sort of underworld of london how she
gets away with it i love it and i can't
say what happens at the end but you and
eloise the character louise claudia you
guys have such an incredible dynamics it
seems that you guys are friends on and
off screen how does it feel to be able
to bring you know season one was such a
massive hit now season two's gonna be a
massive hit to be able to do this
together
it means a lot it really really does and
it's funny because she's in australia at
the moment and last year we got to do
all our press tour together and i really
miss her
face
and i was just saying it's really
strange without you i feel like you know
i'm missing my right arm my little buddy
um she's just a sweetheart she's such
she's such a wonderful person i'm really
grateful to you know when you're playing
that dynamic
you wish for it to be someone that you
really get on with but it truly she's
just kind and generous and lovely i'm so
so glad it's her and it's so interesting
too with this show and you see that
dynamics between youtube but also you
and his the brother uh and find a
suitable match and i find that's so
interesting that marriage is such a
conversation now when a lot of people
don't talk about it very much so why do
you think this show is so i guess
reflective of why people really enjoy it
talking about marriage and finding a
suitable match yeah it's really funny
because i think that you know history
changes society changes but people
inherently say this
and you know i feel like
it's so interesting because
you know women's position in society
we're in a lot better position now but
yet still you know we do crave some of
those traditional things and it can be
seen as you know sort of so traditional
to on it or so subversive to on it but i
think ultimately the show is about love
and finding love and you know even like
the friendship between penelope and
eloise judy aquino writes the book says
that's one of the most important love
stories in it but penelope
is a lover like she is like deeply in
love with colin bridgeton
little girl he is the be-all and end-all
for her so it's funny i think it yeah it
explores so many different types of love
but
yeah in so many different ways
what's a suitable match
what is considered a suitable match for
nicola
for me
i don't know i think harry styles isn't
available so i don't know what to say
he's a good choice he's a good choice
and nicholas who doesn't like about
harry styles right
yeah and i love your passion statements
i have to say follow you on social media
and everything you wear is just so
elegant so beautiful and to compare that
fashion to that era did you like any
elements of it
oh god you know i think yes certain
things i mean i wear this one dress this
season which is a this pink beaded
number that i wear at a country ball and
it was so stunning but it weighed a ton
i had to run upstairs and at one point
and they were like can you run quicker
and i was like no i physically can't but
i mean this show is part of the reason
that i met my stylist amy croisster you
know and said you know
because i used to sort of shy away from
things that passed me like i'll just
throw something on and yeah yeah
and then when i was in these costume
fittings i was like this stuff is
amazing i just really want to like go
all out and just have fun and explore
and it's just been like a really fun
lovely side to things that i've yeah
yeah i love it
and this show is kind of steamy i mean
there's a lot of passion especially
season two and some of the scenes i was
like okay did you tell your family your
friends that it was going to be a steamy
kind of season one in season two
yeah i mean i didn't really know what to
say like my mom when she found out i was
doing a period drama she was like oh
downton abbey and i was thinking it's
not down yeah
it's not my
finale
um so i did end up you know sort of fast
forwarding the quite racy episode with
her um and at first you know now she
calls um jonathan bailey the tree hugger
because of you know that scene in season
one where he's sort of up against a tree
doing something unmentionable
so she's kind of all about it now um but
also
i have you know penelope season you know
we have four seasons commissioners so
penelope season is definitely happening
so i'm sort of now getting heart
palpitations thinking like it was all
it's all funny when it's someone else
now i'm like oh okay it's becoming less
and less funny i'm like oh oh it's gonna
be so much fun i'm sure and because your
lady whistle down what is some gossip
that's happening in entertainment news
that you would write about
oh
well i was at um a really fun bathtub
party the other night and i was dancing
on a couch with a cast of euphoria but
that's just me writing about myself
well i was like i was like i was dancing
there thinking i'm not cool enough for
this i'm not even remotely cool enough
for this
that's the best i'm glad you had fun
thank you so much and you are absolutely
wonderful so thank you again for the
show and for everything you do thank you
thanks everybody